Have you accepted that where you are is
where you're going to be?
You've already lost,
but something else bronc inside me,
something brewing inside me.
I wanted it to be different.
I was determined to be unique.
I was driven to think big and dream big.
We are being raised in a generation of
people that come up with every excuse in
the book as to why they are not winning
you.
Other reason,
you are not winning.
It's time you get off to a pity party.
Stop complaining about being out of
shape when you never go to the gym.
I stopped looking at your stomach.
When you get out of the shower and your
body and complaining about the way you
look when you're eating everything in
sight and never gone to the gym.
I don't feel sorry for you.
You feel sorry for yourself.
That's the problem
because he didn't work hard enough.
I never want to do
because it didn't work hard enough.
I always believed leaving no stone
unturned.
It's necessary to know that everybody
won't see it,
that everybody won't join you.
It's necessary to know that,
that a lot of people like to complain,
but they don't want to do anything about
their situation that you are an uncommon
breed.
You know,
you have to know within yourself that I
can do this even if no one else sees it
for me,
I must see it for myself.
It's very important for you to believe
that you are the one.